27 c'est le nombre de fois que jean luc
a participé au festival bd de buc
passionné il n'a loupé aucune édition et
possède des milliers de bandes dessinées
le but quoi nous explique son penchant
pour le neuvième art il ya des
scénaristes de bande des fumeurs qui
nous font
qui nous transporte
et ajoutez à cela un dessin qui peut
être
génial génial
alors franchement que demander de plus
alors faire mètres linéaires de tranches
beaucoup beaucoup
en fait non
amédée l'événement était l'occasion de
se faire dédicacer plusieurs bd
parmi elles elle n'a comme une histoire
en deux tomes
elle retrace les aventures de gonzalo
guerrero le conquistador devenu général
mayala franchement je ne conseille
l'achat de cet album c'est du soir vrai
on peut dire c'est une histoire vraie
c'est une histoire en deux tomes sur les
mayas je me suis fait dédicacer vos
doigts de ville
sur l'ouvragé bruxelles 43 le nouvel
alix de monsieur albertini de se coller
passionnés de bd jean luc attend déjà
avec impatience l'édition 2021